the summer olympics are scheduled to
open in japan on july 23rd but this week
the u.s state department issued a no
travel advisory to the country japan is
closed to tourists due to a fourth
coveted surge
the medical community there has
repeatedly warned that the that holding
the olympic games
could be catastrophic to japan's
universal
health care system lucy kraft reports
from tokyo
the olympic torch relay is crisscrossing
japan
by july it's set to pass right here by
tokyo's tachikawa general hospital
but there's no welcome message in the
window the sign says
medical care is at a breaking point stop
the olympics
with nurses understaffed and overworked
caring for coveted patients
the hospital took the unheard of step of
publicly venting their opposition to the
games
director takahashi said if there was
solid scientific
evidence that the olympics won't end up
making the pandemic worse there would be
no reason for us to speak out
prime minister suga has promised a safe
and secure
games with rigorous testing and tight
restrictions on athletes
but with tens of thousands of support
staff media and sponsors
plus japanese fans set to converge on
tokyo
overwhelmed physicians like dr kentaro
iwata
fear the worst what would you say that
the feeling is among doctors like
yourself right now
are you angry are you frustrated well i
i sense some sort of powerlessness
because i don't see any rational or
logics
behind what the japan government
or ioc is saying regardless of the risk
or danger or
problems surrounding the olympic games
they would just go
forward because they want money japan
has already invested 25 billion dollars
in the olympics
the most expensive games ever canceling
the event would cost billions more
meanwhile japan is in a race against
time to vaccinate itself
when the games start in late july under
current plans only about a third of the
country will be vaccinated
fueling fear about an olympic-sized
super spreader event
for cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo one can only hope the situation
improves dramatically over the course of
they still have
almost two months to go before yeah and
go ahead yeah we still don't know if
athletes american athletes potentially
will be impacted by this ban
and you hope that if athletes are there
that they've been vaccinated
lowering the risk of potential spread or
getting it themselves there's also there
are issues of
who comes with them that there's so much
that that goes into this right the last
number i saw was only about just
five percent of the population in japan
vaccinated they're talking about maybe a
third
by the time the olympics come so we'll
see